[Música]
estamos hartos de esa gente que viene a
saquear nuestra Costa este video fue
grabado por un pescador Franco guyanes
que regularmente denuncia en Facebook la
pesca costera ilegal practicada por
embarcaciones extranjeras de madera
llamada tapullies en el departamento de
ultramar francés ubicado en Sudamérica
desde hace varios años embarcaciones
procedentes de surinam Guyana y Brasil
pescan en aguas francesas donde la
población de peces está más protegida
Pero según este pescador el problema ha
empeorado año tras año
público estos vídeos para alertar a las
autoridades del saqueo de peces en
territorio francés
[Música]
cada vez que es algo me cruzo con unos
20 te apoyas siempre el récord que puedo
contar fue hasta 43 tapuyas en un día
Si siguen pescando así Creo que dentro
de dos años no tendremos peces
ejercicio
el pez más codiciado por estas
embarcaciones es un tipo de corvina
debido a sus vejigas natatorias este
órgano interno le permite controlar la
profundidad a la que flota en el agua el
kilo se vende a unos 130 euros en la
Guyana Francesa y entre 1000 y 3000
euros en los mercados asiáticos estas
embarcaciones que llegan a las costas
Franco guyanesas suelen pescar durante
la noche y se esconden durante el día
especialmente entre los manglares Esto
es lo que se ve en los vídeos publicados
por un pescador de Guyana que reside en
surinam según las fotos que publica en
su cuenta de tiktok En comparación con
la flota Franco gullanesa estos barcos
suelen utilizar redes más largas con
mallas más estrechas los ojos de las
mallas que traen son muy pequeños es
decir que recogen todos todos los peces
que miden menos de tres centímetros esto
destruye el recurso
ahí vemos una tortuga muerta atrapada en
las redes de los tapoyas que venían de
surinam o Guyana Esta es la consecuencia
de unas redes muy largas
Víctimas de capturas accidentales el
número de tortugas laúd que van a
depositar sus huevos en las playas
Franco guyanesas ha descendido un 95% en
sólo 20 años según la WWF en septiembre
del 2022 está ong sobrevoló la parte
occidental de la Guyana Francesa y no ha
visto ni tortugas marinas ni delfines
algo inédito desde que comenzó a vigilar
esta zona
ilegal es consecuencia directa de la
sobrepesca en las aguas de los países
vecinos que se han desplazado a las
aguas de guayana francesa en los últimos
años periodistas de nuestra redacción se
pusieron en contacto con el
representante la organización de
pescadores de surinam quien asegura que
la mayoría de las embarcaciones ilegales
que navegan en las aguas de la Guyana
Francesa proceden de Guyana pero el
representante de la agregación de
pescadores de este país afirma que los
barcos de su nación van muy poco a las
costas de Guyana Francesa
una de las razones es que está demasiado
lejos se tardaría unos cuatro días en ir
a la guayana francesa a pescar
sería demasiado costoso la ventaja de ir
a pescar a la guayana francesa es que
los franceses son muy estrictos con la
explotación de sus recursos
Así que siempre hay muchos peces
según Los Pescadores Franco guyaneses a
corto plazo deberían haber más medidas
en las fronteras además de más sanciones
severas para impedir la llegada de
barcos extranjeros a aguas que en el
marco de la ley son francesas y son de
la Unión Europea
buenas noches a todos voy a mostrarles
una de las cirugías más útiles que he
visto y que se está poniendo muy de moda
en Los Ángeles
[Música]
la operación que se practicó esta joven
española es una bichectomía una
intervención quirúrgica que consiste en
extirpar el tejido graso de las mejillas
en tiktok con el hashtag vocal fat
removal o extracción de grasa bucal en
español miles de usuarios grababan sus
operaciones o también hablan de sus
deseos de operarse estos vídeos ya han
generado decenas de millones de visitas
y han hecho que la bichectomía sea la
tendencia actual en cirugía estética
Los partidarios de esta intervención
quirúrgica resaltan que la operación no
deja cicatrices y tampoco es muy costosa
en Francia por ejemplo cuesta entre 3000
y 3.500 euros sin embargo la bichectomía
conlleva riesgos como lo Explica el
doctor Michelle cirujano plástico que
alerta a través de su cuenta de tiktok
sobre algunas de estas operaciones Esta
es una intervención que permite vaciar
las mejillas la bichectomía consiste en
eliminar las masas grasas acumuladas en
la mejilla si realiza una pequeña
incisión en la mejilla lo que permite
tener un rostro un poco más afinado
personalmente no realizó este tipo de
operación porque uno es arriesgada 2 la
evolución de la cicatriz intraoral no es
tanto el problema sino la evolución de
los huecos de la cara esta grasa que se
elimina se derrite naturalmente en la
cara a medida que envejecemos esto
significa que cuando eliminamos
demasiada grasa Cuando somos jóvenes a
veces podemos tener una cara muy
esquelética más adelante
mi concepción de la cirugía estética
está intrínsecamente ligada a la cirugía
reconstructiva es para los complejos de
los pacientes y arreglamos esos
complejos a veces trabajo con psicólogos
para tratar este trastorno dismórfico
corporal con algunos y algunas pacientes
que vienen al consultorio y que no
tienen complejos que solo quieren
mejorar ciertas partes de su rostro lo
que a mí no me parece razonable me tomo
mi tiempo los veo varias veces en la
mayoría de los casos rechazo la
intervención
[Música]
llegamos al final de este episodio de
Los observadores de France 24 Recuerden
que ustedes pueden comunicarse con la
producción del programa para enviarnos
sus historias sus vídeos y también sus
fotografías nuestros contactos aparecen
en sus pantallas nosotros nos vemos en
una próxima oportunidad Hasta pronto